what i want to do in this video is come
up with the formula for the arc length
of a curve that's defined in polar
coordinates so if this curve right over
here is r is equal to f of theta how do
we figure out the length of this curve
between two thetas say between theta is
equal to well let's say in this case it
looks like between theta zero radians
and say pi over two radians but two
between any two bounds for r theta
so the way we're going to do this and at
any point you get excited or inspired
you definitely should pause the video
and see if you can run with the formula
for arc length when you're dealing with
something in polar form but the way that
we're going to tackle it is the exact
same way that we tackled arc length when
we were dealing with standard
rectangular coordinates
so let's take a little small section of
the arc length
let's take a little small section i'm
going to blow it up
so let's call this right over here this
is our infinitesimally
this is our infinitely small or
infinitesimal sized uh our piece of our
arc length i'm going to call it d s
and obviously this is a lot bigger than
maybe what you would imagine when you
think of infinitesimal but then if you
integrate together all of the ds's if
you integrate together all of the ds's
then you're going to have you're going
to have the length of the actual curve
that you care about so we could say that
the length is going to be all of the
ds's integrated all of the infinitely
the infinite sum of all of these
infinitely small
all of these infinitely small ds's
now to actually put this in terms that
we can relate to in terms of r's and
thetas i'm first going to relate this to
x's and y's and then relate the r's and
thetas to x's and y's which we have seen
before when we've converted between
polar form and rectangular form
so we know
that this ds
is going to be equal to our infinitely
small change in x squared
so if this is our going from this point
to that point that's our change in our
arc length but this distance right over
here would be our change in our x all
right that is dx and i'm writing
everything as differentials which is a
little bit mathematically i guess we
could say hand wavy or loosey-goosey but
it gives you a good conceptual
understanding of where this comes from
you could if we were a little bit more
precise we could take dx we could do
delta x's and then eventually take
limits and all the rest but i'll just go
with this because it makes a little bit
at least for my brain a little more
conceptual sense
so that's if that's our change in x when
we go from that point to that point
then
this is our change in y
when we go from this point to this point
d y and we've seen this before when we
got our justification for the arc length
formula rectangular coordinates we could
say that d s is going to be equal to
the square root of dx squared
dx
squared plus dy squared and this just
comes straight out of the pythagorean
theorem
plus
dy squared and then if we could
integrate these then we're kind of in
the same place
but how do we how do we get these in
terms of r's and thetas
well to do that we just have to remind
ourselves
what x is in terms of r and theta and
what y is in terms of r and theta
so x
we know is going to be equal to r
cosine
of theta and we first saw this when we
just
first were going back and forth between
polar and rectangular coordinates
and y
is going to be r
sine
of theta
and now we can use this to
say what dx and what dy are going to be
dx
is then going to be equal to and we have
to remember that r is going to be a
function of theta so actually let me
write it this way let me just rewrite it
so x we could also write it as
f of theta times cosine theta and y
is equal to
f of
theta times sine of theta
so now what's dx
dx
is going to be this is just we're going
to apply the product rule here it's
going to be f prime of theta derivative
of the first expression times the second
one
times cosine of theta plus the
derivative of the second one well the
derivative of cosine of theta is
negative sine of theta so we'll see
minus
sine theta
minus sine theta times the first
expression so f of theta
that was just the product rule that's
our dx
and then of course d theta
d theta another way you could have said
if you if you treated these
differentials like numbers you could
divide both sides by d theta you'd have
the derivative of x with respect to
theta is this business right over here
so those are equivalent equivalent
statements and let's do the same thing
for d y
so d y
same again by the product rule is going
to be
f prime
f prime of
theta
times sine of theta
plus
f of theta
times the derivative of sine of theta
which is just cosine of theta
cosine
of theta
and now if we want to figure out what d
s is we're going to take the sum of dx
squared and dy squared so let's do that
so
d
x
dx squared is going to be equal to we
just need to square all of this business
so i'm just going to square this and
then multiply that times d theta squared
so that's going to be equal to
this is going to be
f prime
of theta
squared
cosine
squared theta minus 2 times the product
of these
minus 2 times
f prime of theta
f of theta
cosine theta
sine theta
and then this one squared so negative
times negative is positive so plus
f of theta
squared
sine squared
sine
squared theta so that's dx squared
and then of course we have the d theta
well i'm not done yet then we have the d
theta
squared and now let's figure out what d
y squared is
so
d y
squared is going to be equal to
well this term squared oh i have to
forget this d y is going to have a d
theta at the end don't want to forget
that
and so over here this is going to be
f prime
of
theta
squared
sine squared
sine squared theta and then two times
the products of these so plus
two times
f prime of
let me
f prime of theta f of theta it's a
little bit hairy but we'll see in a few
seconds it's going to clear it's going
to clean up nicely f of theta cosine
sine
cosine theta
sine theta and then we just want to
square this
plus
f of
theta squared
cosine
cosine squared
theta
and then d theta squared
d
theta squared now let's add these two
together
so let's add them together and what are
we going to get so
if we add
dx squared and dy squared we're going to
get so dx
squared plus d y squared
plus
d y
squared is equal to
so over here we have cosine squared
theta times f prime of f prime of theta
squared and then sine squared theta
times f prime of square f prime of theta
squared so we can factor out an f prime
of theta squared so it's going to be
equal to so if we factor these
characters out it's going to be
f prime
of theta
squared times
times
cosine squared theta cosine squared
theta plus sine squared theta
plus
sine
squared theta and we see that that's
going to simplify nicely that this is
just going to be equal to
one
that's just one basic trig identity
and then these middle two terms actually
cancel out this is negative of this so
these two
cancel out
and then over here we can factor out an
f of theta squared
so
we could factor out an f of theta
squared so it becomes
plus
f of theta
squared times
sine squared theta
sine squared theta plus cosine squared
theta
plus cosine squared theta well that
simplifies nicely this is just going to
be equal to 1.
and then we have these and then this d
d theta squared is multiplied times
everything
so
so everything right over here is going
to be so times d theta
d theta squared you could almost view
these as the coefficients on d theta
squared we added those two coefficients
so this is going to clean up nicely now
so this simplifies as
dx
squared
plus d y squared
plus
d y squared is equal to
is equal to
f prime
of theta
squared plus
f of theta
plus f of
theta
squared
and then all of that times
let me do this in a new color actually
all of that times d theta squared
actually that i've already used that
color i'll use the magenta all of that
times d theta squared
d
theta squared
now we know that d s is going to be the
square root of this so let's write that
so ds
is equal to the square root of this
which is equal to the square root of
this
which is going to be equal to well we
can factor out a this is the square root
of d theta squared is just going to be d
theta so we can just take that out and
we are left with
we are left with
f prime of theta squared
f prime
of theta
squared plus f of theta squared
plus f of
theta
squared and now we took it taking a d
theta out of the radical if you put it
in it's d theta squared you take it out
it's going to be d theta
d
theta
so this is interesting so if we wanted
to integrate them so if you wanted to
integrate this if you want to integrate
this if you want to integrate this
you just want to d integrate
this right over here and you would
integrate it from your starting theta
maybe we could call that alpha to your
ending theta beta and just like that we
have given ourselves a reasonable
justification or hopefully a
conceptual understanding for the formula
for arc length when we're dealing with
something in polar form
if you have r is equal to f of theta
you find what f prime of theta is or you
could think of it as the the derivative
of r with respect to theta square that
add that to f of theta squared take the
square root and then integrate with
respect to theta from out from alpha to
beta and so this right over here
our arc length is going to be equal to
this
right over here in the next few videos
we will actually apply this